Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay.
Zuerst bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Willi Jäger.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Willi ist ganz einfach. W-I-L-L-I.
I wie Ida oder Emi?
I wie Ida.
Und Jäger, J, Ä, also A umlaut, G-E-R.
Alles klar. Herr Jäger, oder?
Ja, richtig.
Alles klar. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59, noch.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. Mai 1966.
Ich wäre also bald 60.
Alles klar.
Wie groß sind Sie aktuell?
Ja, ich bin, wachsen tue ich nicht mehr, ich bin 1,74.
1,74.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, jetzt wiege ich noch 75 Kilo.
Alles klar. Was fühlst du heute zu uns?
Was kann Ihnen helfen, Herr Jäger?
Ja, also ich hab so komische Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Und am Anfang war das so, dass ich das nur hatte,
wenn ich also festes Essen gegessen hab,
wenn ich ein Brot gegessen hab.
Da hab ich mir nicht so viel dabei gedacht.
Hab gedacht, ja Mensch, hast du vielleicht nicht gut gekaut,
hast ein bisschen schnell gegessen.
Und jetzt hab ich aber das Gefühl,
als ob mir da so ein Kloß im Hals ist.
Und dass das wirklich beim Schlucken so drückt,
hier oben im Brustbereich.
Das ist ganz unangenehm.
Und ich mag schon gar nicht mehr essen und trinken.
Deswegen hab ich auch jetzt in letzter Zeit ordentlich schon abgenommen,
weil es mir gar nicht schmeckt.
Ich mag wirklich nicht mehr essen und trinken.
Und selbst wenn ich nur Tee trinke oder Kaffee trinke,
hab ich das Gefühl, das tut beim Schlucken ganz doll weh.
Alles klar. Es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, das hat eigentlich so vor drei Wochen ungefähr, würde ich sagen,
drei, vier Wochen hat es angefangen.
Und wie gesagt, erst hab ich das nicht so richtig ernst genommen,
aber jetzt wird es halt immer schlechter.
Tritt man die Schmerzen nur beim Schlucken oder auch in Ruhe?
Nee, sonst eigentlich nicht.
Manchmal muss ich allerdings so aufstoßen.
Das ist auch ein bisschen unangenehm.
Okay. Alles klar.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen drückend oder drinnend?
Also überwiegend würde ich sagen drückend.
Das ist so das Hauptproblem.
Und ja, auch so ein bisschen stechend sind die auch.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von eins bis zehn,
wobei eins sehr leichten, zehn sehr stechend Schmerzen entgegricht?
Das sind halt Schmerzen, vielleicht so in der Mitte, ja, irgendwie so was.
Fünf oder sechs, oder?
Ja, fünf.
Alles klar.
Haben die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Ja, das hat eigentlich langsam angefangen.
Also irgendwann ist es mir halt aufgefallen, dass es beim Essen unangenehm ist.
Und dann ist es halt immer mehr geworden.
Wie gesagt, am Anfang habe ich gedacht, Mensch, hast nicht gut gekaut, ne?
So musst du ein bisschen darauf achten, dass du besser kausst.
Aber dann ist es halt gar nicht besser geworden.
Und jetzt ist es eben schon, wie gesagt, selbst wenn ich einen Schluck Wasser trinke, tut es weh.
Okay.
Schmerzen und Schmerzen in einer anderen Körperregion aus?
Nee.
Das ist nur da so hier im Halsbereich und hier so unterm Hals,
direkt oberhalb von der Brust.
Okay. Alles klar.
Und husten muss ich auch zwischendurch.
Ich habe also einmal dieses, dass ich so aufstoßen muss und manchmal habe ich auch so, dass ich so husten muss, ja.
Haben Sie Blut beim Husten bemerkt?
Blut ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ne?
Alles klar.
Haben Sie erbrochen oder ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, übel? Ja, also erbrochen habe ich nicht.
So ein bisschen schlecht ist mir.
Und ja, wie gesagt, ich habe so wenig Appetit und ich fühle mich total schlapp.
Also ich habe so das Gefühl, so ja, als ob einer den Stecker gezogen hat.
Ich bin schlapp und kann mich nicht gut konzentrieren und bin einfach müde.
Ich habe das Gefühl, alles geht viel langsamer, so wie in Zeitlupe, ja?
Alles klar.
Sind Ihnen Heiserkeit oder Mundgeruch aufgefallen?
Also ist mir jetzt selber nicht aufgefallen.
Heiser, ja manchmal so nach dem Aufstoßen, dass ich dann denke so, jetzt ist es ein bisschen heiser.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist, das Schlucken tut mir ja weh und dann kommt aber ganz viel Speichel, ja?
Also da und dann muss ich wieder schlucken und das ist so ähnlich wie beim Zahnarzt,
wenn man weiß, man will eigentlich nicht schlucken und dann hat man das Gefühl, dann kommt ganz viel Spucke, ne?
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Durchfall, Verstopfung?
Verstopfung, ja, also Verstopfung habe ich in letzter Zeit häufiger.
Haben Sie dunklen oder schwarzen Stuhl bemerkt?
Ja, das ist mir tatsächlich aufgefallen.
Zweimal war das jetzt schon, dass ich gedacht habe, das sieht ja komisch aus, ja.
Das war ganz dunkel, das stimmt, ja.
Okay, Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie Verstopfung haben. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ach, das habe ich eigentlich schon länger.
Okay, wie wird das behandelt?
Ja, also wenn mir gar nichts geht, dann nehme ich halt so eingeweichte Pflaumen oder ein bisschen Flohsamen,
rühre ich mir in Wasser ein und dann geht das eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich konnte akutisch nicht verstehen, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen?
Also eigentlich so Hausmittel, Flohsamen und eingeweichte Pflaumen.
Das hilft eigentlich ganz gut.
Und das schmeckt auch, also diese Pflaumen, das schmeckt auch ganz gut, so getrocknete Pflaumen und das in Wasser eingeweicht.
Hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, das ist eigentlich so ein ganz guter Trick.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost?
Nein, also Fieber bin ich nicht, nein.
Schwitzen Sie oft in der Nacht?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Durchschlafstörungen, Durchschlafen oder Einschlafen?
Ja, also ganz gut schlafen kann ich tatsächlich nicht.
Aus welchem Grund haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Weiß ich nicht, das habe ich aber auch noch nicht lange.
Also dass ich dann irgendwie nachts aufwache und irgendwie unruhig bin oder so, ja.
Ich kann nicht wieder einschlafen.
Okay, wir haben ja schon erwähnt, dass Sie schlechte Appetit haben.
Ja, wirklich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, zum Glück noch nicht.
Leiten Sie an irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, also ich habe schon seit 15 Jahren so einen Alterszucker.
Und dann nehme ich so Tabletten, eine morgens und eine abends.
Und damit ist das eigentlich ganz gut so eingestellt.
Und?
Was ist der Name?
Das heißt Ikandra.
Ikandra?
In welcher Dauer nehmen Sie?
Was steht denn da drauf?
Da steht 50 zu 1000 steht da drauf.
50?
Zu 1000.
Okay.
Und dann nehme ich morgens und abends je eine.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Ja, also man hat mal festgestellt, dass ich so ein bisschen Herzrhythmusstörungen habe.
Und deswegen nehme ich regelmäßig morgens Makuma.
Und der Hausarzt kontrolliert das dann auch hin und wieder.
In welcher Dauer nehmen Sie?
Das kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen.
Der Hausarzt kontrolliert das immer und sagt mir dann immer, wie viel ich nehmen soll.
Wurde innere Werte kontrolliert oder?
Ja, ich glaube so heißt dieser Wert. Ich weiß das nicht so genau. Ich kenne mich da nicht aus.
Okay.
Wurde eine bestimmte Diagnose gestellt?
Ja, die haben gesagt, dass ich so ein bisschen Herzstolpern habe.
Dass das Herz nicht ganz gleichmäßig schlägt.
Und deswegen soll ich dieses Blutverdünnungsmittel halt nehmen.
Damit es da keine Gerinnung gibt.
Okay. Wie oft nehmen Sie Makuma? Wie oft? Jeden Tag oder?
Ja, eigentlich jeden Morgen, ja.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts. Zum Glück bisher hatte ich nie irgendwas.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden? Oder Stationen im Krankenhaus aufgenommen worden?
Ja, also damals mit dieser Zuckerkrankheit, als man das eingestellt hat.
Da war ich mal kurz im Krankenhaus.
Und dann, ach das ist schon lange her. Das war aber nur eine ambulante Operation.
Da hatte ich an dem linken Ellenbogen, hatte ich so einen Schleimbeutel.
Und der ist operiert worden. Das war aber eine ziemlich kleine Geschichte.
Okay. Seit wann sind Sie operiert worden?
Das ist 12 Jahre her jetzt.
Alles klar. Am linken Ellenbogen, oder?
Am linken Ellenbogen, ja, genau.
Haben Sie noch weitere Operationen?
Naja, als Kind habe ich irgendwann mal die Mandeln rausbekommen, ja.
In welchem Alter sind Sie operiert worden?
Wie alt war ich da? Das war kurz vor der Einschulung, da muss ich so sechs gewesen sein.
Alles klar.
Gab es Komplikationen?
Nee, damals, nee. Also kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Das ist alles ganz fix gegangen.
Alles klar. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf weitere Medikamente ein?
Nee, nur das was ich Ihnen gesagt habe. Das Makuma und dann dieses Zuckermedikament.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen irgendwelche Medikamente oder Lebenslaufe?
Ja, also ich darf tatsächlich keine Deklofenak bekommen.
Das hat man irgendwann mal festgestellt, dass ich das nicht vertrage.
Tabletten oder Creamen?
Nee, da habe ich mal Tabletten bekommen. Das ist mir nicht bekommen.
Und dann habe ich eine Allergie gegen Gräser.
Also wenn die Gräser blühen, dann habe ich halt tränende Augen und geschwollene Nase und so.
Und Urlaub auf dem Bauernhof ist nichts für mich.
Wie äußert sich die Deklofenak-Allergie?
Ja, da habe ich so einen juckenden Ausschlag bekommen.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Vollständig, ja. Gegen Covid oder so. Da bin ich irgendwie dreimal geimpft worden, aber jetzt dann auch nicht mehr.
Und sonst ist das schon alles ziemlich lange her.
Rauchen Sie Herr Jäger?
Ja, also eine Packung am Tag rauche ich schon, ja.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Wann habe ich angefangen? Also ungefähr mit 20 und seitdem rauche ich eigentlich durchgehend.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so ein Bier trinke ich, ja auch zwei Bier trinke ich eigentlich jeden Abend und am Wochenende trinke ich dann auch gerne mal so ein paar Gläser Schnaps noch dazu.
Alkohol Schnaps, ok.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Ja, das habe ich nie gemacht.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich weiß nicht ob das chronisch ist, also mein Vater, der war sich, der hat einen Mavengeschwür und meine Mutter, die lebt schon gar nicht mehr.
Die hatte Darmkrebs und ist daran gestorben. Die ist aber, naja, sie ist auch fast 80 gewesen.
80, ja. Es tut mir leid. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei Geschwister.
Sind Sie gesund?
So viel ich weiß, haben die nichts, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Jäger?
Ja, also ich arbeite in so einer Telefonzentrale.
Ok, was machen Sie genau beruflich bei der Arbeit?
Ja, also ich bin da an der Pforte und stelle die Verbindungen her und wenn Besucher kommen und nach dem Weg fragen, dann schicke ich die halt in die richtigen Büros.
Und wenn jemand anruft, verbinde ich halt mit den richtigen Mitarbeitern in der Firma und so.
Ok, sind Sie verheiratet?
Meine Frau ist verstorben, also ich bin alleine.
Ok, Sie lebt allein, oder?
Ich lebe alleine, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind schon groß, ne?
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei Kinder haben wir, aber die sind wie gesagt schon aus dem Haus.
Ok, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich wüsste nicht, dass Sie irgendwas haben, ja.
Herr Jäger, wir sind mit unserem Gespräch fertig.
Ich habe meine Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich will natürlich wissen, was mit mir los ist, wie man das besser machen kann, dass ich wieder ohne Probleme essen und trinken kann.
Und natürlich habe ich auch ein bisschen Angst, ob ich vielleicht genauso wie meine Mutter eben Krebs habe.
Und ja, das sind natürlich so meine Sorgen.
Und jetzt will ich natürlich wissen, wie es weitergeht, ne?
Ich kann Ihre Sorge gut verstehen, Herr Jäger.
Warum denken Sie am schlimmsten, das Schlimmste?
Ja, bei meiner Mutter habe ich das halt erlebt, dass die an Krebs gestorben ist, ne?
Ich kann Ihre Sorge gut verstehen, aber im Moment können wir nichts ausschließen.
Bevor ich Ihnen etwas Genaues sagen kann, brauche ich alle Informationen.
Informationen habe ich Ihnen ja alle gegeben, alles was Sie wissen wollten.
Und Untersuchungen.
Untersuchungen, was machen Sie denn jetzt mit mir?
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen, Blut abnehmen und gegebenenfalls Magenspiegelung durchführen.
Sie müssen alle Ergebnisse abwarten.
Sobald wir alle Ergebnisse haben, werden wir wieder ausführlich besprechen.
Okay, aber muss ich da jetzt hierbleiben?
Ja, Sie müssen hierbleiben. Bitte warten Sie hier. Ich komme gleich.
Okay, gut.
Danke schön.
Ja, sehr gut. Okay, möchte jemand noch was Zusätzliches fragen?
Ja, ich wollte eine Frage stellen. Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Jäger, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben abgenommen, aber Sie wollten nicht sagen, wie viele Kilogramm abgenommen.
Oh, das waren jetzt drei Kilo in relativ kurzer Zeit.
Relativ kurzer Zeit. Danke schön.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Jäger, Sie haben nur Schmerzen beim Schlucken oder Erschmerzen der Schlucken?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass da ein Widerstand ist.
Widerstand.
Ja, also dass da so ein Kloß im Hals ist. Und es drückt, als ob ich nicht genug gekaut habe.
Und leiden Sie an Sortebrünen?
An was?
Leiden Sie unter Sortebrünen?
Ja, manchmal habe ich das so, dass ich so aufstoßen muss. Und dann ist es natürlich sauer.
Und kommt Ihnen die Nahrung wieder hoch, wenn Sie essen?
Ja, das sage ich ja gerade.
Danke.
Ja? Okay.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Bevor Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden kommen, mögen Sie die Speise heiß und trinken Sie sehr heiß?
Ja, lieber als kalt. Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Lieber als kalt, ja. Okay.
Und haben Sie Blut in den Spucken gesehen oder nicht?
Wo habe ich Blut gesehen?
In den Spucken.
Warum? Auspucken?
Ja, auspucken.
Nee, da habe ich aber ich... Ja, also... Nee, da habe ich nichts gesehen.
Sie haben nichts gesehen.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Gerne.
Ist das erstes Mal oder hatten Sie das schon mal?
Solle ich Ihnen beschwerden? Das hatte ich noch nie.
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Danke schön.
Sie sagen Bescheid, Herr Doktor, wenn Sie so weit sind, ne?
Nee, der hat nichts eingenommen dagegen. Der wüsste auch nicht was.
Zum Beispiel, ich merke es mir nicht.
Nee, nee.
Herr Kolke, sind Sie bereit oder brauchen Sie etwas Zeit?
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Ja, fangen wir an.
Bitte schön. Gehen Sie los.
Schönen Tag, Herr Oberers.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Es geht um Willi Jäger, der 59 Jahre alt ist.
Wie alt ist er?
59.
59, okay.
Der 59 Jahre alt ist.
Bei einer Größe von 1,74 Meter wiegt er aktuell 75 Kilogramm.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor wegen seit 3 bis 4 Wochen bestehender Dysphagie
und Oedinophagie.
Die Schmerzen waren am Anfang bei einer festen Nahrung,
mit der Zeit auch bei einer flüssigen Nahrung aufgetreten.
Oh ja.
Begleitet bestehen auch Globusgefühl in der Brust und Pyrrhosis und Ruktus.
Außerdem klagt er über Husten ohne Blut und Mausia.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 5 von 10 beim Schlucken bewertet.
Die Schmerzen haben langsam begonnen.
Der Schmerzkarakter beschrieb er als drückend und stechend.
Außerdem besteht bei dem Patienten Inappetenz, Fatigue, Abgeschlagenheit sowie Hypersalivation.
Darüber hinaus berichtet er von Konzentrationsstörungen und Melena.
Während der Aufstossen berichtet er von leichten Heiserkeit.
Die Fragen nach Fieber, Futterfrost, Schwitzen, Erbrechen wurden verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese gab in der Sonne in Form von Durchlaffstörungen.
So wie Obstpassionen seit langer Jahren.
In der medizinischen Vorgeschichte fand man Diabetes mellitus type 2 seit 15 Jahren.
Die Extrazistole wurde vor 12 Jahren wegen der Bositis am linken Ellenbogen operiert.
Im Alter von 8 Jahren wurde er eine Tonsilektomie unterzogen.
Bezüglich der Medikation nimmt er Ikandra 50, 1000 Morgen und Abends.
Markuma macht jeden Morgen INR-Werte ein.
Die Klofenak-Allergie ist eine Erkrankung von Eczantham und Pruritus.
Die Gräser-Allergie ist eine Erkrankung von Rhinokonjunktivitis.
Unser Patient ist vollständig geimpft. Er schaut 20 Jahre lang eine Packung täglich.
Unser Patient trinkt zwei Bier jeden Abend und ein paar Schnaps am Wochenende.
Die Erkrankung ist sehr hoch.
Die Familie zeigt die Ventriküli beim Vater.
Die Mutter des Patienten ist im Alter von 18 Jahren an einem Kolonkarcinom verstorben.
Unser Patient hat zwei gesunde Geschwister.
Er arbeitet im Telefonzentrale und ist in der Klinik.
Er arbeitet im Telefonzentrale und ist verwitzt.
Er hat zwei gesunde Kinder und lebt alleine.
Er lebt alleine, ok.
Die Analysten zeigen, dass er auf einen Oesophagus-Karcinom ist.
Was könnte es noch Differentialdiagnostisch sein?
Die Analysten zeigen, dass es noch Differentialdiagnostisch ist.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ich bestimme zuerst die Vitalparameter.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Bei der Palpation kontrolliere ich den Hals, ob mögliche Schwellungen, Lüftknoten, cervicale oder supra-clavikale Lüftknoten verliegen.
Und worauf achten Sie noch?
Bei den Patienten kann Anämie-Zeichen sein.
Deswegen kontrolliere ich Hautfarbe.
Was machen Sie weiter an Untersuchungen?
Nach der Untersuchung sollte ich ein kleines Blutbild, CRP, Nierenwerte und Leberwerte bestimmen.
HB ist wahrscheinlich auch noch sinnvoll, um die Anämie auszuschließen oder zu bestätigen.
Um die Anämie festzustellen, würde ich verraten, dass Hemoglobinwerte bestimmen.
Dann würde ich bei diesen Patienten eine digitale und rechte Untersuchung durchführen, um eine Melena festzustellen.
Wie geht es weiter mit den Patienten?
Was würde man diagnostisch noch machen?
Im Bereich der Diagnostik würde ich die Ösophagografie und die Diagnostik von der Rautinuskopie veranlassen.
Um mögliche Raumförderung und Karsenom zu erkennen.
Sehr gut.
Dann würde ich sagen, sind wir sicherlich auf der sicheren Seite, wenn wir diese Untersuchungen alle gemacht haben.
Halten Sie mich bitte über den Patienten auf dem Laufenden.
Dann schauen wir mal, was er hat.
Was wäre denn zu machen, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose tatsächlich bestätigt?
Könnten Sie bitte noch mal sagen?
Wäre es therapeutisch machbar, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt?
Sollte sich meine Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich zuerst einen Venosenzugang legen.
Dann würde ich die Analyngtheterapie einleiten.
Analyngtheterapie, Antiemethikatherapie einleiten.
Danach Protonpumpen und Hämmer verabreichen.
Ein chirurgisches und gastroenterologisches Konsil anfordern.
Das ist bestimmt. Da müssen Sie nachgucken.
Und ein onkologisches Konsil.
Also halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über den Patienten.
Vielen Dank.
Das war in meinen Augen eine sehr schöne Anamnese und auch ein sehr kompletter Bericht.
Sie haben sehr konsequent alles, was Sie abgefragt haben, auch in guter Formulierung weitervermittelt.
Das war sehr vollständig, würde ich sagen.
Mir hat auch gefallen, dass Sie wirklich gute Übergänge gemacht haben.
Dass Sie gesagt haben, in der Familienanamnese ergab sich, dass das nicht so abrupt kam, sondern dass Sie das wirklich sehr schön verbunden haben.
Und auch tatsächlich sehr konsequent die Fachbegriffe angewandt haben für die ganzen Symptome, die der Patient geschildert hat.
Das war sehr schön.
Wo ich immer so ein bisschen draufwarte, ist tatsächlich noch eine winzige Formulierung, weil ich die eigentlich so treffend finde.
Der Patient hat ja gesagt, hier oben tut es ihm weh beim Schlucken.
Und ich denke immer, das sind so diese klassischen Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein.
Also retro sternale Schmerzen. Das sind ja diese Herzschmerzen, die da sitzen.
Aber eben auch in diesem Fall, weil da die Speiseröhre runterläuft, dass er da dieses Klosgefühl hat.
Und das hätte man vielleicht noch bringen können, aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, war das wirklich sehr, sehr vollständig.
Und Sie haben auch sehr schön logisch in der Reihenfolge den Patienten befragt zu seinen Symptomen und sind eigentlich ja auch sehr schnell auf dem richtigen Weg gewesen.
Sie haben ja gleich in die richtige Richtung weiter gefragt und haben dann diese Fragen nach zum Beispiel Nachtschweißfieber, sozusagen B-Symptomatik.
Haben Sie aber auch erst abgefragt, nachdem Sie eigentlich schon diese ganzen Schlucksymptome und so was vernünftig abgefragt haben.
Die hatten mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen. Eine Winzigkeit, eine Winzigkeit, weil es ein grundsätzliches Thema ist.
Sie haben gesagt, er raucht seit 20 Jahren. Er raucht seit dem zwanzigsten Lebensjahr.
Da der Patient 59 Jahre ist, raucht er seit 39 Jahren. Das ist ein deutlicher Unterschied.
Das sind 39 Pack-Years im Vergleich zu 20 Pack-Years. Das ist ein wirklich wichtiger Unterschied.
Seit dem zwanzigsten Lebensjahr, das ist eine Zeitdauer von 39 Jahren, wenn der Patient 59 ist. Sind für uns einig, ja?
Haben Sie verstanden, was mein Problem ist?
Ja, ja, ja. Ich habe total falsch verstanden.
Ja, also seit er 20 Jahre ist, nicht seit 20 Jahren. Und das macht halt wirklich viel aus.
Und das ist diese Tücke in den deutschen Formulierungen. Ich weiß nicht, wie das im Türkischen ist, aber das ist tatsächlich eine Schwierigkeit,
dass man da nicht das verwechselt. Seit oder wie lange. Das ist der große Unterschied.
Ansonsten alles astrein gelaufen. Ich würde sagen, Sie können selbst kritischen Münchner Prüfern sehr gelassen entgegentreten.
Und brauchen sich eigentlich, würde ich sagen, um diese sprachlichen Sachen keine großen Sorgen zu machen.
Das war alles ziemlich einwandfrei. Ja, kann man nicht viel dran meckern. Ja?
In diesem Sinne würde ich sagen, können wir für heute Feierabend machen?
Wenn Sie mögen, sehen wir uns am Dienstag, Quatsch, am Donnerstag wieder. Wie ist die Lage? Dr. Pupil? Oh, er ist nicht mehr da.
Jetzt kommt der Applaus endlich für Sie. Ja, alles gut gelaufen. Ja, da kommt er. Dr. Pupil, sehen wir uns am Donnerstag.
Ja, ja, gerne. Entschuldigen Sie mich. Alles gut.
Ich habe eine Meeting an der Gerät. Auf der anderen Seite. Ich konnte gleichzeitig nicht zwei Unterricht folgen. Entschuldigen Sie mich.
Ich höre jetzt nicht. Ja, gerne. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie es mitbekommen. Es war wirklich eine astreine Anamnese und ein sehr schönes Ars Asgespräch.
Ich denke, dieser Kollege muss sich keine Sorgen machen. Wir sehen uns am Donnerstag gerne wieder.